hey
i'm here to talk about building fairer
models for finance
i'm andrew weeks i'm a data scientist at
air
air is a fintech startup and also a
regulated credit reference agency we've
pioneered these of first-party data data
collected
directly from consumers to create
distinct credit insights for lenders
we've been doing this for nearly seven
years now
in the uk and have recently expanded
into the u.s market too
i've personally been working in the
startup space for nearly a decade now
and have been with air for nearly six
years of its journey
including work from quite an early stage
on our products in the uk and the us
so as you can imagine this background
this
topic is something that's important to
us as a company
and me personally and because as a
credit reference agency
we don't lend money ourselves but work
with lenders who
do it's also something of course that's
important to
to our partners my own background
is on the tech side and it's certainly
been an interesting journey for me
learning how financial institutions such
as
banks credit card issuers
lenders and others think about fairness
so fairness and bias
are rightly hot topics in machine
learning at the moment which
is fantastic to to see
it's been a concern in finance for a
long time
because finance has been having an
impact on people's lives
for a long time the core role that
financial institutions play in most
people's lives
mean that bad decisions can
significantly limit opportunities
and often the ability to participate
fully in society
i just want to spend a couple of minutes
looking
at the history or a couple of examples
from the history of
the us although this is not
unique at all to to the us of course
find
similar patterns similar results in
in many other countries
one of the most important pieces of
legislation
in this space is which was passed in the
1970s is the equal credit opportunity
act
which banned credit discrimination on
the basis of protected
this was initially just gender and
marital status but it was extended
a couple of years later to cover more
characteristics
including race and ethnicity at the time
it was quite common to ask uh newly
married women
to reapply for credit uh in their
husband's name
and with their husband's job it was also
quite common to discount a wife's income
after marriage either entirely or in
part
when calculating if a loan was
affordable this incidentally
had a disproportionate impact on
black women as they were more likely to
be contributing a higher
a few years earlier than that the fair
housing act
was passed which banned discrimination
on the basis of
race and national origin and other other
protected characteristics
and one of the significant
impacts of this was that it banned
redlining
a practice where a map of a city would
be
drawn or districts would be drawn on
this map indicating the riskiness
of each neighborhood and these were used
by
many institutions including banks
in practice though the riskiness of a
neighborhood was often determined by
community demographics and it meant that
black families were unable to get access
to mortgages or other financial services
needless to say this discrimination had
real impact
on people's prospects at the time and
these things are still being felt today
through a lack of generational wealth
these problems have certainly not gone
away but
it is good that we have at least made
some progress in these areas
so what is fairness a nice definition
i came across is is this one
fairness is the absence of any prejudice
or
favoritism towards an individual or
group
based on their inherent or required
characteristics
it's very broad it's not limited to
certain categories and it covers
discrimination
against both groups and individuals
in finance though the definition of
fairness
is narrower it usually just covers
protective characteristics defined in
statute in the law
such as gender race ethnicity or
disability
it usually only covers outcomes
so bias that might be there in
inputs or features is less of a concern
and again usually is focused on
group fairness so a minority group
suffering discrimination
is of concern rather than specific
individuals within that group
in the u.s there are three main types of
discrimination
that are outlawed in financial services
prohibited basis using protected
characteristics
like gender or race directly to make a
decision
so for example deciding only to lend to
men
disparate treatment not using a
protective characteristic
directly but still intentional
discrimination
against a group because of that
characteristic so
we've just seen an example which is
redlining which was
often a proxy for race and was
deliberately so
and disparate impact which is
unintentional
but still gives negative outcomes for
those people in a protected class versus
the majority default class
in some in some instances an example of
this
is education level if
individuals in a protected class have
had less opportunity to get access to
education
the 80 rule is often used as a threshold
to demonstrate whether discrimination
has taken place or not
it's not formally part of financial
services regulation
it comes from employment law but it has
been widely adopted in the industry
and it says that you should be hiring or
lending
to people in minority groups at at least
80 of the rate as the default group
so if we were hiring
or lending to people with disabilities
at
only 50 percent of the rate of the
default majority group then we would not
pass this test
in the uk the situation is a bit
different
the uk does have the equality act which
prohibits discrimination
on the basis of protected
characteristics again such as disability
or gender marital status race and others
but the uk regulator the financial
conduct authority
or fca has adopted a principles-based
regulatory regime in a principles-based
system
the principles that the fca wants
wants you to adhere to are defined but
is then left
to banks and others to decide how best
to implement them
so lenders are expected not to
discriminate
but there are a lot fewer specific rules
such as disparate impact or disparate
treatment as in
in the us in practice though
lenders often adhere to a very similar
approach
one of the principles that the fca does
think
important is the impact of any fairness
concern
i've pulled a few examples here from a
nice recent paper
by the fca looking at this
and talking about how much are
individuals harmed by this
if they're harmed minimally then that's
not so much of a concern
to the fca but if they're harmed
significantly that will be more of a
concern
how many people are harmed if it's just
a small minority then that's less of a
concern
whereas there is a significant group of
people that's more of a concern
and how are firms how are lenders
discriminating
if it's transparently and based on
changeable behavior
such as switching from one product to a
cheaper one
then that's less of a concern but if
it's base if it's hidden the
discrimination
and on the basis of intrinsic
characteristics then that is more of a
concern
again all of this is focusing on the
impact
of the of the uh the bias
that we're seeing here the scale and
severity of that
so how do we go about building a risk
model well
the typical approach of a large lender
would probably be something like this
they try to build a parsimonious model
building the
simplest version of the model that they
can
this is good practice anyway but is
particularly important here
as it will help a lot with validation
they will also tend to favor using small
simple pieces of
to construct their models as these are
easier to reason about
rather than doing it all in one big
black box
they will favor interpretable models
which
in practice often means
something like linear regression or a
decision tree
and explainability is also very
important being able to explain
the decisions coming out of the model in
the case of
adverse action notices from consumers
gdpr requests
or regulators inquiring
the other side of this which is perhaps
not so exciting but is very important
is validating the model having a
comprehensive model governance process
covering the model use model quality
model definition analysis and of course
ongoing monitoring
is really important
part of this will be agreeing fairness
metrics up front
and of course making sure that they are
met
during the model development
a lot of fairness assessments carried
out
still tend to be quite qualitative which
is
asking questions like is this a
justifiable feature to include in a risk
model
is the feature moving in the right
direction as risk increases
this has limitations it can be
subjective
if you're not careful it's possible to
miss interactions
but one of the nice things about it is
that it is
strongly tied to the real world impact
unfortunately i can't use one of our
internal data sets
so i'm going to use the home credit
default risk data set from kaggle
and this is a really nice data set for
checking fairness and finance
it's pretty clean it's fairly large with
300 000 rows and it contains some
protected characteristics that we can
use to check for bias directly
if we were using this data set for real
there are
a few features we want to be careful
with
like age and gender education
types of job which are quite often
gendered in this in this data
and a few other things too
if we look at the default rate the
number of people who didn't repay their
loans
in the training set this is just over
eight percent
so this is probably a reasonably prime
or low risk
population default rates can be
less than one percent for a very prime
population
and could be as high as 40 to 60 percent
or
even higher than that for a subprime
population
i'm going to use gender as the example
characteristic here
there are more women in the data set
than men at a ratio of about two to one
but both enough of both for this
analysis
it turns out that the default rate for
each gender varies quite a lot in this
data set
at seven percent for women and ten
percent for men
i'm quickly going to resample the
data set so there are equal numbers of
people who repaid
and defaulters who did not repay the
loan
so we don't have to deal with those
class imbalances here
this means the default rate for the
entire data set
is now about 0.5
if i build a simple logistic regression
model on the training set
the model doesn't seem to overfit the
performance on the training and test
sets are very similar
and it seems pretty stable too if i
build it again
using a different train test split
i built the first model here using all
of the features i had
including gender
i'm going to be using auc as the
performance metric
auc is a common measure for building
lending models
as it's quite easy to move from that to
a risk score
and for making lending decisions using
that
the auc on this model
is about 0.67 which
is not great for a population as prime
as this but
it's good enough for this exploration
so how can we define fairness in code
we can define fairness as the ratio
between
positive predictions in the model for
each of the protected groups
which is gender here if the model is
completely fair
then the positive predictive rate
for each rope will be the same
here g is the protected characteristic
and d are the model predictions
similarly we can define the 80
rule to say that the ratio of positive
predicted rates between the two genders
is no less than 0.8
the model i just built does not quite
meet that threshold
splitting by gender the model predicts
that women will default at about
45 percent and men will default at a
rate of
nearly 60 percent so the ratio between
these two
is about 76
but we know from the data set that women
are quite a bit more likely to repay the
loan
so this is perhaps not the best test
here
so let's look at a couple of metrics
that are commonly used for checking
fairness
equal opportunity and predictive
equality
for equal opportunity to be true the
true positive rate
is equal across the protected groups
here female and male a crew positive
is a person who did pay back the loan
and where the model predicted they would
a difference in true positive rate is
unfair
because it would give fewer
opportunities to the minority class
predictive equality or false positive
rate parity
is a similar idea but here we're trying
to equalize the false positive rate
across the protected groups here a false
positive is a person
who we said would repay the loan but
didn't
predicting the quality is more useful
for lending
as if we were actually making lending
decisions using
this model we would not have any data
for false negatives
as we wouldn't have lent to those people
so we can't calculate the true positive
rate
there are ways around this using reject
inference
where we're trying to estimate if
someone we rejected
would have repaid but it's not ideal as
it relies on quite a lot of assumptions
another fairly common approach is to
accept
a small number of people below your
score cutoff for a period of time
though again you need to be careful that
you're lending responsibly
if we look at the equal opportunity true
positive rate ratio
and the predictive equality false
positive rate ratio
for the model i've just built the
results are pretty awful
the true positive rate ratio
we can see the opportunity for men is 64
of that as for women and the false
positive rate
ratio is even worse at 50 percent
both of them are well below the 80
minimum
we'd like to reach
if we remove gender as a feature and
rebuild the model
the auc drops a very small amount
but the fairness metrics are now quite a
lot better
our equal opportunity true positive rate
ratio is now
79 so it nearly meets our threshold
though the predictive equality false
positive rate ratio
is still quite low at 70 percent
as a third experiment what if we replace
gender with the mean of that value when
we're making predictions
this lets the model use that protected
feature when training
so there's less chance that we'll try to
find proxies for janna
but then we remove it when the model is
being used live
the model performance is again very
similar to the previous one
so we haven't impacted our ability to
discriminate
but the equal opportunity is now much
better we get a 91
true positive rate ratio for men
compared to women
and predictive equality false positive
rate ratio has also improved a lot
to 88
this was a very quick analysis and i
skipped over a lot of important checks
that we'd want to do
on the model and data but it does show
that it's possible to get some pretty
dramatic improvements
in fairness without impacting the
overall performance
much at all
so which metrics should we use are equal
opportunity
and predictive equality a good choice
here
i think it depends i think
you have to relate it back to the wider
question
thinking about what the product is that
we're building here
what the demographic is that we're
targeting
about our use case for example
if we were offering mortgages there's an
argument that a false positive
is much more likely to be damaging than
a false negative we as a lender
would lose a lot of money potentially
and it's also likely that the borrower
would lose their home
it seems much safer to be conservative
and also important for fairness
that the false positive rate is no
higher
for the minority class
on the other hand if we were offering
loans
to people who may have difficulty
getting access to credit
otherwise then a false negative
may be more harmful as they may not have
many other opportunities to get that
credit
but generally it's a good idea to look
broadly
use multiple fairness metrics and think
about what impact
it may have on both you as a lender and
on your customers
if your model is biased for that metric
so as we've just discussed it's unlikely
that we'll be able to move bias
entirely from our models but there are
some other mitigations
that we can use no less harmful impact
is one we demonstrate that we can't
build
another model with less bias and similar
performance
using a different social features or a
different model building approach
age is an example here people who are
older
tend as a rule to have a longer credit
history
than younger people for obvious reasons
but a long credit history is also
something that is really quite
predictive
of being good credit risk so
its use is usually allowed and usually
quite
beneficial
comparing it to a reference model is
another way
we can mitigate so if your model has
some bias
but compared to your current model or
an industry standard model you can
demonstrate that there is
less bias then you are
at least improving the situation
compared to where things are now
the product use case is another
interesting
way of looking at this for example if
your model
is being used to give a second look
to reassess people who have been
rejected by
a main model then
if you're giving people a second chance
the worst case is
that they will be rejected again and the
best case is of course they will now be
accepted
so the outcome of the model is a net
positive
even if there is some bias in how it
performs
so the data set we've just looked at had
protective characteristics in it
but often this won't be the case and
if it's not the case then it's a lot
more difficult to check the bias
and i don't have any great answers to
this
unfortunately one of the main solutions
in this space is the cfpb the consumer
financial protection bureau
one of the u.s regulators who have
released a
bisg the bayesian improved
surname geocoding methodology
this is an industry standard and it is
widely used by lenders in the us
but it certainly has limitations
the surname-based approach has
difficulty
separating non-hispanic blacks from
non-hispanic whites because
their surnames are relatively uh similar
and
the geography-based
approach has difficulty identifying
hispanics and asians because those
groups
are not particularly spatially
segregated
so if we look ahead a little bit
i think we might be on the cusp of some
interesting and
possibly even quite profound changes in
finance
the typical approach of large
institutions at the moment
is not really using many
advanced machine learning techniques for
making lending decisions
major lenders are quite conservative and
careful
and regulators also need to be convinced
of this this approach um to make sure
that they're satisfied it's it's
uh safe and fair
um but this is starting to happen
um a number of fintechs are
starting to use this sort of approach
using more advanced techniques and big
lenders are
definitely paying attention to this
the regulators also have released a
number of papers
and consultations over the past few
years and
i'm quietly hopeful that over the next
year
or two or maybe three we will
start to get advice from them that this
sort of approach
is permitted and possibly even
encouraged
and there's a significant opportunity
if if that does happen there will be
more opportunities for giving access to
credit
for credit invisibles and others who
have
been shut out of a lot of the financial
system at the moment because
we can build more sophisticated models
using alternative data for example
and hopefully more accurate models as
well
we will be in a position hopefully to
explain the decisions of these models
for consumers and regulators through
surrogate models such as lime
or chap and
there'll also be opportunities to
hopefully emphasize
and focus a little bit more on
quantitative assessments
of features and data
and the fairness of those as well as the
quality of approaches at the moment
i think both of these are important and
it would be good to
encourage both
if we look ahead a little bit for
machine learning and
data science this is possibly not
what you want to hear as it's largely
about process
but a lot of the regulation in
financial services while onerous exists
to protect people from
bad outcomes and machine learning is
having an increasingly
large impact on our lives in many areas
now
and i think the things that we as data
scientists
and machine learning engineers can learn
from the checks and balances that
exist in finance adopting wholesale what
an international bank does would be
completely disproportionate for a
small startup or probably even for our
large tech unicorn
but having a good governance approach
will
go a long way to preventing bound
outcomes inadvertently happening
having a diverse team who care about
fairness is really important but
the responsibility for checking
adequately for buyers shouldn't just
fall on
their shoulders make it part of how
your company does things as well
like finance we as technologists and
as people building machine learning
models especially
are becoming a key part of many people's
lives
that's a real privilege but also a real
responsibility
so please check
your models are fair and
give the best outcomes for as many
people as possible
thank you i find the intersection
between
finance and tech those worlds are
a fascinating area so if you do too i'd
love to
discuss chat further hear ideas
and learn more because i still have a
lot to discover
so please get in touch via the contact
details
on here and the notebook is also
available on github at the link on the
slide
thanks again